we just got the first teaser trailer for
racket Ralph - and hidden in there are
some sneaky Disney Easter eggs including
Aladdin's lamp Star Wars favorites Yoda
and Chewbacca plus our first look at
Ralph breaking the Internet
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and this is my wreck-it Ralph 2 trailer
breakdown for all the Disney and movie
references you might have missed don't
forget to let me know about any other
cool details you spotted in the comments
below thanks to footage shown at d23
last year we already know that the
wreck-it Ralph sequel is going to
feature loads of characters from other
big Disney properties one of which is
Lucasfilm Star Wars in fact the d23 clip
showed c-3po and a bunch of
stormtroopers along with x-wings and TIE
fighters all appearing in a scene that
also included Disney's Princesses Dumbo
and Ironman now while we don't get to
see those particular Star Wars figures
in the new trailer for Ralph breaks the
Internet there is a hidden hat tip to
the galaxy far far away in mr. lip wax
office where if you look closely at his
shelves you'll see a couple of
decorative plates featuring none other
than the little green Jedi Master Yoda
and wookie copilot Chewbacca if you want
to catch some other nice nods to Disney
movies then check out the items on sale
in the background while Ralph and
vanellope are staring at that cat
painting on ebay there's a magic lamp
like the one that appears in Disney's
1992 animated musical Aladdin which is
guessing a live-action remake with Will
Smith starring as genie and there's also
a cast-iron frying pan like the one
featured in Disney's animated movie
Tangled
although it's eBay listing only says
that the pan is great for everything
from frying chicken to grilling a
tortilla it can also make a very
effective weapon as Rapunzel Flynn and
the Royal Guard all show very well
during the course of tangled
oh mama I have got to get me one of
these when the arcade owner mr. Litwack
uses his computer you can spot a
reference back to the first wreck-it
Ralph movie take a look at the bottom
right-hand side of the screen and you'll
find a document called letter to Nana in
the first film Litwack mentions his
scene our Nana several times
mr. lip whack what's the trouble
sweetheart looks like the games gone
cuckoo Nana sorry sweetie
here's your quarterback what about the
game I'll have someone look at it
tomorrow but if you can't fix it it
might be time to put all Ralph and Felix
out to pasture like my Nana the final
pancake scene of Ralph's feeding a pool
bunny so much that it explodes seems
like a tease of Ralph's doing what the
movies title says breaking the Internet
the little girl who was playing the
pancake milkshake game until Ralph took
over was certainly horrified when she
saw the bunny exploding the kitty for a
little while
no the kitty gets the milkshake bunny
this scene also reminded me of similar
moments in the Willy Wonka and Monty
Python movies in Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory Violet Beauregarde
blows up like a giant blueberry after
she takes Willy Wonka's experimental
three-course dinner gum and the wreck-it
Ralph scene is also a callback to mr.
creosote the glutton from Monty Python's
the meaning of life who explodes after
he finishes an enormous meal with an
after-dinner mint by the way the little
girl who Ralph traumatizes reminds me of
baby Moana from Disney's last movie and
it might be a way of including a piranha
Easter Egg to repay the wreck-it Ralph
Easter Egg that appeared in Moana the
older Moana will also be appearing in a
separate scene in wreck-it Ralph -
together with a group of other Disney
Princesses although we didn't get to see
them in this teaser hopefully they'll be
in the next full trailer there's
obviously going to be a ton of
pop-culture references and online jokes
in wreck-it Ralph - a couple that pop up
in this trailer of fake prize scams and
clickbait articles
really these 10 child stars went to
prison number six will amaze you that
sounds interesting
now there's a good number of actors
who've ended up in jail but I wonder if
this could be a jab at former Disney
child star Lindsay Lohan he's well known
for getting into trouble with the law
and his served time as a child Lohan
starred in Disney films such as The
Parent Trap and some of the studio's TV
movies and just last year she suggested
on Instagram that she should play Ariel
in a live-action version of Disney's The
Little Mermaid of course given that
Ralph and vanellope are exploring the
Internet there's also bound to be some
more adult themed jokes in the movie I
did notice that in the Internet
reception hall there's an IP address
lookup area with signs pointing to among
other things and Zipp services and
browser history clearance and you can
make what you want of that before I
finish I want to note that we don't know
a lot from this teaser about what's
going on back at the video arcade from
the brief shots of a very empty parking
lot and the way things are lit inside
the arcade plus the fact that game
central station doesn't look very busy
there's a sense that the amusement
arcade might be losing business perhaps
due to online competition and a brief
synopsis of the movie indicates that
Ralph and vanellope have ventured online
to look for a replacement part for her
game sugar rush so let me know if you've
got any theories about what else you
think might be going on so what did you
think of the teaser trailer for Racquet
Ralph - and do you feel it looks as good
as the first film let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you love animation check out my recent
picks are videos on Incredibles - and
Coco by tapping the screen right here
and if you enjoyed this don't forget to
like share and subscribe to get all my
new videos thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers